the first example says find the fourth
term in the binomial expansion of 3x
plus 2y to the fifth power now one way
to do this of course this is not the
best way is to take this quantity and
multiply it have five groups and
multiply it all together but that's
going to take a long time to foil all
that out combine like terms and so on so
what we do is we use the binomial
expansion theorem which is binomial
means two terms and we expand it out
using that binomial expansion theorem
now one thing we want to talk about or
just quickly review is Pascal's triangle
so remember Pascal's triangle each row
starts with one and ends with one and
then to get the term below it you just
add the two terms above it so that's how
I'm getting this triangle here but
another way to do this is you look at
the row like this is row zero Row 1 Row
2 Row 3 Row 4 see like if we're looking
at row for each of these terms is 4
choose 0 4 choose 1 4 choose 2 all the
way to 4 choose 4 so notice how it
always starts that whatever the row is
choose 0 and then it works its way up
from there okay now when you work with
combinations we use this formula here
NCR equals n factorial over n minus R
factorial R factorial so I'll give you
an example like say if we wanted to
expand out a plus B to the fourth power
well what we can do is we can say well
we're on the fourth row so we're gonna
do 4 choose 0 and then what you do is
you take the first term a to the fourth
power and you take the second term B to
the 0th power now when you go to the
next term you're going to do 4 choose 1
this is going to be a to the third power
see I'm going down but the second term
is going to be B to the first power
notice I'm going in ascending order or
up so if we continue on you can see 4
choose 2 now we're going to be at a
squared B squared and I'll just carry
that over here 4 choose 3 a to the first
B to the third and lastly 4 choose 4 a
to the 0 and B to the fourth now one
thing I want you to notice real quick is
that see how this second number here
this R value see this is 0 and this
second terms power sale that's a 0 1 1
- to see the pattern also notice that
when you add these exponents four plus
zero is equal to four that's the power
that's the that's the role that we're
working with right so if we recognize
that pattern we can use that to zero in
on a specific term so for example here
say lets us find the fourth term in the
binomial expansion of 3x plus 2y to the
fifth
now follow how I'm gonna do this this
makes it a lot easier to do it in this
way so I'm gonna take 3x that's the
first term
- y that's the second term okay and then
what I'm gonna do the fourth term now
notice over here like if I wanted to
find the let's just say I want to find
the second term this is the first term
this is the second term but see how this
is just four choose one that's because
we're starting at zero so when I go over
here to the fourth term I'm actually
gonna be at three and this is the fifth
role so this is going to be 5 choose 3
okay so I went down to this fifth row
the fourth term would actually be 5 - 3
because you're going 0 1 2 3 right now
remember the pattern how I said that
this our value and the second term is
power see how they always match so if
this is a 3 here this is going to be a 3
here this is going to be a 2 because 3
plus 2 adds up to 5 that's the the power
okay so now all we have to do is
simplify this down so 5 choose 3 I'm
going to be using this combination
formula here so this is 5 factorial over
5 minus 3 which is 2 factorial times 3
factorial and this is 3 squared which is
9 x squared 2 cubed is 2 times 2 times 2
which is 8 and now if I simplify this 5
factorial is what it's 5 times 4 times 3
times 2 times 1 all over 2 factorial
that's 2 times 1 times 3 factorial
that's 3 times 2 times 1 but you can see
those are cancelling this is 20 over 2
which is 10 so I get 10 times 9 times 8
is 72 so I get 720 x squared Y cubed
they want that particular term they want
that whole group so that's gonna be your
answer there now we're gonna go to the
next example but I know a lot of
students right now are preparing for the
AC T and the new SAT so I just want to
let you know about my two courses my
huge AC t-- math review video course and
my huge SAT math review video course we
go through
we go through formulas we go thru
typical problems that you would see on
those tests on the math section we talk
about how to recognize them and how to
approach those problems so go over there
check out the link and there's three
free lessons in both those courses you
can take those lessons get a sense of
you know how the course is laid out and
if it's right for you and you'll get
benefit right right from the start from
taking those lessons and if you want to
go further you can purchase the course
and you know learn more about how to
prepare for those two tests but let's go
ahead and jump back into this video
talking about finding a specific term in
the binomial expansion of 4x minus y to
the ninth power we want the seventh term
here so hmm so what are we going to do
well what I'm going to do is I'm going
to say for X negative Y okay so those
are our two terms I want the seventh
term and we're here on the ninth row so
this is gonna be nine choose six now
you're probably saying Mario isn't the
seventh isn't it the seventh term right
but remember how we started at zero so
that means zero through six this is
actually going to be the seventh term so
one last remember this our value in the
second term is power those always going
to match and then these two powers are
going to add up to nine so this must be
a three so that's a quick way to get
that particular term that you're looking
for just remember it's the seventh term
it's actually going to be one less
because you're starting at zero so let's
go ahead and simplify this now so I'm
using this combination formula nine
choose six this is actually nine
factorial over nine minus six three
factorial times 6 factorial 4 cubed is
four times four times four and then this
is a negative 1 to the sixth power which
is going to be negative one y to the six
now notice this one was plus I didn't
really put a plus here but when it's a
minus he can think of this as a negative
one so that's why I did negative one to
the sixth power which is just going to
be negative one to the sixth power like
that okay so I'm just distributing so
now if we simplify what do we get well
we get nine factorial which is 9 times 8
times 7 times 6 all the way down to one
six factorial six five four three two
one you can see those are cancelling
three factorial is 3 times 2 times 1
okay and then here we have a negative 1
to an even power as positive 1 so that
to be 64 X cubed Y to the sixth things
are shaping up here okay let's see we've
got 3 goes into 9 3 times 2 goes into 8
4 times so now we have 12 times 7 which
is 84 times 64 right so what's 84 times
64 that's five thousand three hundred
seventy six five three seven six X cubed
Y to the sixth and now you can see we've
zeroed in on that seventh term so I hope
that helps you to understand how to work
with the binomial expansion theorem
better I'll link to some other videos I
did talking about the binomial expansion
theorem a little bit more if you want to
get some more practice otherwise
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you in the future
math videos I'll talk to you soon